it was like someone just took a massive
rock and just hit me on my ribcage
my name is cindy mafu and i live in
california i am a mother of
two toddlers and they keep me busy
i enjoy taking walks we're walking in
the trails we're walking in the woods
swimming i love the beach
don't ask me to get into the water in
california it's freezing
the day of
the heart attack it was a normal
saturday
i was doing my housework
started mopping and when i was mopping i
noticed i started sweating
and not just like small sweat like
profusely sweating and i went and i
washed my face
i came back carried on with my work and
i started sweating again
i went back and i washed my face and i
thought this is odd
because they the cool air was going in
the house when i was washing my face
everything just seemed to be going black
and i called
my husband because that's when i felt
like i was very dizzy
he helped me to our room and
um as i was trying to sit on the bed
i felt this crushing pain on my chest
i told my husband all the pain i'm
feeling
pain in my chest and i was just holding
my chest so tight every it felt like it
was squeezing and everything was
crushing then i felt the pain starting
to go
on my left arm squeezing me tight at
that time he called 911.
in my mind
i was saying there's no way i'm having a
heart attack
emts came they asked if uh
i suffered with panic attacks if i had
high blood pressure if i was stressed
they asked me a whole lot of questions
they did an ekg
and they said nothing was wrong with my
heart
and because they gave me the option to
stay home i agreed and i stayed home
i laid down and when i laid down it felt
like the pain was getting
intense and more than what i was feeling
and
my husband was like i'm taking you to
the er because of covert
i had to walk in by myself i was checked
into the er
they started connecting me to monitors
giving me ivs and things like that you
could tell
they're now moving at a different pace
so in my mind
already i knew something was wrong but i
didn't know exactly what it was
a cardiologist came and she then
confirmed
that my blood work
and the ekgs done at the hospital
confirmed that i have
in fact had a heart attack when i was
given the news
i just lost it i was immediately prepped
to go into theater so they could look
at my arteries and my heart to see what
was going on and what was found is that
i had a tear
in my left descending artery which is
called the widowmaker
and i had a spasm and i had
a blockage blockage in my right artery
after i came back from the procedure
i was given a diagnosis that i have
what is called spontaneous coronary
artery dissection
which is known as scad
i was in the hospital for a few days
seeing different doctors
explaining my condition thank god i did
not need
any intervention so they treat me with
just medication
i think the worst part about this
is it's such a lonely
experience i have now found a group
a close group the american heart
association
gave me that resource that is for
survivors of scared
they give the support and the emotional
support that i
really feel that i've needed
i think this event has helped me
to just remember to live in the now
to live for today i'm holding on to
seeing my kids grow up and
seeing my baby girl go to kindergarten
to see my son going to a petting
farm so he can see a real pig he's
obsessed with pigs and cows
and i'm holding on to that that i will
have those opportunities
and to hopefully grow old
with my husband god knows the desires of
my heart
and it's all in his hand and he has
my future planned out for me